herzlich willkommen zur zdf heute live
haben sie es vielleicht auch schon
gemerkt wer einen handwerker beauftragt
oder noch schlimmer wäre ein haus bauen
will der muss ganz schön in die tasche
extrem in die tasche greifen denn die
materialkosten explodieren völlig egal
ob holz metall stahl dämmstoffe alles
wird knapper alles wird teurer die
kosten explodieren denn überall gibt es
lieferengpässe dachdecker klagen sogar
über baustopps und stornierungen von
aufträgen weil der einfache dachlatte
nicht mehr zu bekommen ist und dabei
würde vor im vergangenen jahr in
deutschland so viel holz aus den wäldern
geholt wie nicht mehr seit der
wiedervereinigung jahrelang klagte die
deutsche wirtschaft über
fachkräftemangel dass das den motor
sozusagen ab wirkt dann letztes jahr im
corona jahr war es ein mangel bei den
aufträgen und jetzt ist es der
materialmangel der zu schaffen macht wie
passt das alles zusammen was sind ihre
erfahrungen
was sind ihre fragen wir wollen sie
klären mit zwei gästen zum einen haben
wir hier frau julia hartmann professorin
für nachhaltige supply chain management
an der ebs universität in oestrich
winkel
schön dass sie gekommen sind vielen hat
und wir sprechen mit jemand der selbst
anpackt selbst macht tut und dinge
kreiert aber jetzt wegen des material
mangels auch vor problem steht nämlich
mit dem youtuber jonas winkler
funktioniert jonas winkler ist
vorsprünge ich eigentlich
produktdesigner nach dem studium
entdeckte er seine liebe zum werkstoff
holz und wurde tischlermeisters seit
2018 zeigt der gebürtige hannoveraner
seine arbeit auch auf youtube mehr als
200.000 abonnenten hat er und die
versorgt er nicht nur mit allerlei
unterhaltung sondern vor allem
fachwissen und praktischen tipps rund um
die themen heimwerken und holz jonas
winkler schülern abend toll dass sie
auch noch mit dabei sind so jetzt mal
gleich die erste frage an sich sie im
hintergrund da doch einiges aus holz
sägen das regal ist das jetzt besonders
kostbar geworden stehen sie wirklich vor
dem problem
dass sie sag mal die einfache holzlatte
nicht mehr bekommen tatsächlich leider
ja
es ist so dass wir zwar spezialisiert
auf massivholz sind aber natürlich durch
die arbeit auch für youtube immer wieder
andere andere materialien nutzen müssen
und so ist es halt so dass tatsächlich
auch wir diese krise aktuell sehr sehr
stark mitbekommen denn die gerade
angesprochenen dachlatte bekommen wir
tatsächlich im moment auch nicht
das heißt die simpelsten sachen es geht
jetzt nicht nur um was ich was teures
holz ganz spezielle sonder arten sondern
sie sagen die einfache kiefer fichte
holzlatte euro teure massivholz das
können wir nach wie vor bekommen und
damit ist unser lager hinter mir auch
randvoll das problem ist gerade für
viele kunden aufträge im echten tischler
alltag brauchen wir aktuell andere
materialien zb multiplex platten und co
und die bekommen wir leider aktuell
überhaupt gar nicht das heißt selbst mit
den kontakten wie ich mittlerweile habe
habe ich keine chance an diese
materialien hand zu bekommen und das ist
natürlich gerade bei kundenaufträgen
echt ein riesenproblem bei den kunden
irgendwie klar machen musst du hast du
an gezahlt aber liefern kann ich immer
mit mich und ich meine auch überhaupt
gar nicht wann das wieder geht also eine
schwierige sache schon die ersten user
schreiben hier thorsten stein märz zum
beispiel bei youtube meinen brennholz
lieferant hat nichts mehr auf lager
kein scheitholz normalerweise decke ich
mich zu dieser zeit scheint anscheinend
normalerweise günstig zu sein immer für
den nächsten winter einen pustekuchen
er konnte nicht mal sagen wann es wieder
welches geben wird ist das wirklich so
frau hartmann das alles auf einmal
material einfach teurer wird sozusagen
ist es selbstverständlich dass man ein
metall ein paar schräubchen und an holz
kommt wir haben durch die pandemie eine
stark veränderte nachfrage und diese
nachfrage schlägt sich jetzt gerade auf
die lieferketten durch
wir hatten in der pandemie zuerst ja
diesellok downs in der zeit haben wir
alle angefangen unsere häuschen zu
renovieren und dort in möbel zu
investieren in verschiedene andere
materialien
in den usa und in asien erholt sich die
wirtschaft jetzt gerade auch sehr heftig
und sehr schnell
das heißt dort sind noch einmal vermehrt
aufträge in die lieferketten gegeben
worden und das wird gerade tatsächlich
zu diesem materialengpässen also da
sitzt man nun corona technisch zu hause
und fängt an zu werkeln und zu machen
da sagt der youtuber ist eine tolle
sache ich weiß jetzt gar nicht hat man
das so gemerkt dass zu coroner zeiten
auch immer mehr abonniert haben immer
mehr gesagt haben do it yourself ich
will da mitmachen und jetzt auf einmal
schreiben die youtuber vielleicht ich
habe es auch knapp
tatsächlich kann ich diesen trend bei
mir leider nicht beobachten wir haben
immer ein recht stetiges wachstum
aber wir haben tatsächlich durch youtube
schon vor einem jahr die ersten
auswirkungen von dieser krise gemerkt
ich hab da mal gefragt ob ihr jemand
irgendwo noch rund stäbe kaufen kann und
das feedback aus der gesamten community
war
nein es gibt nirgends wo welche und das
war wirklich sehr sehr interessant war
zu dem zeitpunkt wusste von uns gar
keiner dass diese krise so tritt
rückwirkend wissen wir aber da waren die
ersten anzeichen schon sehr sehr gut zu
sehen und ich musste dann rund stimme
bestellen für einen kundenauftrag und
ich glaube ich habe viereinhalb monate
gewartet und das ist vorsichtig
ausgedrückt sehr schwer zu argumentieren
warum das so ist weil der kunde
natürlich nicht mehr unbedingt in diesem
prozess drinsteckt die man das als
handwerker selber tut ja und das ist
nicht nur irgendwelche einfachen sachen
sind rund stelle und auch nicht nur
einfach das warten das problem ist bis
etwas kommt sondern eben einfach auch
die preise das ist nicht einfach ein
gefühl das ist nicht nur eine erfahrung
sondern das ist fakt die preise für holz
explodieren momentan das sehen wir mal
in anna graf die preise für schnittholz
sind stark gestiegen allein von april zu
mai verteuerte sich der rohstoff um 33
prozent im vergleich zum mai 2020 hat
sich der preis für das schnittholz sogar
mehr als verdreifacht deutsches holz ist
aber nicht nur hierzulande gefragt
aufgrund der schäden durch zahlreiche
waldbrände haben die usa im letzten jahr
54 prozent mehr deutsches schnittholz
eingekauft als noch 2009 10 auch aktuell
importieren die usa wegen ihres starken
wirtschaftsaufschwungs nach der korona
krise viel deutsches holz
international geht der schnittholz
export aus deutschland aber leicht
zurück also ist das tatsächlich so dass
es nicht nur der deutsche ist er jetzt
auf einmal die ärmel hochgekrempelt hat
er in corona zeiten und das häuschen zu
hause schön macht sondern dass
tatsächlich weil amerikaner also andere
deutsches holz kaufen die preise
hochgehen und sie dastehen und sagen ich
kriege man rundholz nicht mehr
das wird wahrscheinlich so sein also
wenn man das ganze auf youtube bezieht
und nach amerika guckt da gibt es diese
do it yourself seele schon sehr sehr
lange und vor allem auch extrem
ausgeprägt also da macht er wirkt also
nicht nur jeder aber in amerika und
viele viele leute eine werkstatt in der
eigenen garage
wir merken dass das jetzt in deutschland
auch langsam anguckt und wenn man
natürlich dass alles global in einen
topf schmeißt dann wird diese hohe
nachfrage halt irgendwann einfach ein
bisschen zu problemen und ich glaube
dass das gar nicht so sehr jetzt ein
aktuelles problem ist sondern dass das
eigentlich was ganz normales ist bei wir
sind halt sehr globalisiert wir sehen
dass selbst in fichten baum aus
deutschland fährt heute um die welt und
so ist es natürlich auch irgendwie klar
dass dann kleinere oder größere
ansprüche in der nachfrage auch hierzu
ganz großen problemen führen können das
trifft dann selbst denjenigen der
eigentlich sagt ja ich brauche nur ein
ganz klein bisschen holz um etwas was
ich zu basteln oder kleinigkeiten zu
bauen
sie sprechen ist aber schon an jetzt
haben wir gerade gehört die amerikaner
kaufen holz aber der rohholz exporte
weil es gerade die rede von schnittholz
ich habe mich aber informiert rohholz
export aus deutschland ist seit 2015 um
238 prozent gestiegen das kann man sich
gar nicht vorstellen und die hälfte
dieser rohholz exporte also der
baumstamm an sich mit rinde und allem
geht nach china also da hat herr winkler
ja völlig recht komplett auf die andere
seite des globus sozusagen
ist das nicht verrückt ist das normal
oder wir müssen wir damit umgehen
china hat asien generell hat
inzwischen an wohlstand aufgebaut und
das schlägt sich jetzt natürlich auch in
der nachfrage nieder also auch in china
und in asien werden vermehrt familien
häuser gebaut einfamilienhäuser und die
haben natürlich jetzt ein holz hunger
und das ist aktuell mehr als die
chinesische industrie vor ort
produzieren kann deshalb ja das stimmt
natürlich dass dort die nachfrage auch
extrem angezogen ist nachhaltig ja
weniger gleich darüber reden aber ist es
wirklich nur der hunger der chinesen
herr winkler oder sehen sie noch andere
punkte
ich denke was ich von vielen holzfäller
aus meiner umgebung so gehört habe ist
heute zwar glaube ich bei uns in
deutschland sehr sehr lange sehr sehr
günstig und das problem ist wenn etwas
sehr günstig ist
dann gibt es auf leute wie bezahlen
einfach mehr und dann ist es wird ja
auch in ordnung und das was nicht gehört
habe das heißt nicht dass das die
wahrheit ist die chinesen und amerikaner
sind einfach auch bereit mehr zu zahlen
das heißt wenn die nachfrage sozusagen
höher ist als das was da ist dann
gewinnt natürlich am ende der der am
meisten zahlen und wir als deutsche sind
oft gewohnt dass wir einen sehr sehr
guten sehr geringen preis haben und
haben gerade vielleicht jetzt ja durch
dieses ich sage mal ein bisschen geiz
ist geil verhalten ja jetzt den kürzeren
gezogen bei andere eher bereit sind mehr
geld auszugeben
also ist also da muss man sich ein
bisschen an die eigene nase fassen in
deutschland vorne
ich habe jetzt einen winkler nicht hören
kann das allein ist es nicht so ich habe
es auch schon gehört den beiträgen also
über das thema wald gesprochen haben
dass man jetzt auch nicht so sehr klagen
soll wenn die preise richtig explodieren
weil man umgekehrt sehen muss dass die
preise über jahre das es dumpingpreise
gab also mit anderen worten zb der
waldbesitzer gar nichts bekommen hat und
jetzt natürlich sozusagen gerechte
berechtigterweise froh ist wenn jemand
mehr bietet also auch für etwas mehr
geld das ganze vielleicht nach amerika
geht um sozusagen die dumpingpreise die
verluste der letzten jahr auszugleichen
das wäre denke ich eine schöne
entwicklung ich glaube nur dass bei den
waldbesitzern gar nicht so sehr viel
mehr hängen bleibt
sie haben ja noch einige zwischenstufen
in der lieferkette und diese ich werde
gar nicht sagen gewinnen
die bessere kostendeckung die wird schon
vorher abgeschöpft und kommt gar nicht
mehr unbedingt beim waldbesitzer an also
das ist schon ein problem in der in
dieser lieferkette aber durch die
höheren preise wird das nicht unbedingt
adressiert also wir haben keinen
mechanismus der dafür sorgt dass höhere
margen auch in der lieferkette fehr
weiter verteilt werden
aber ist es so dass in der
vergangenenheit holz unwahrscheinlich
will ich ja und man sich jetzt
vielleicht mal nicht unbedingt wunder
soll das jetzt auch mal der preis hoch
ist wir hatten natürlich mehrere effekte
die zusammengekommen sind
wir haben zum einen holz das wirklich
für die produktion bestimmt war wir
haben aber auch sehr viel holz das auf
grund von schädlingen oder den
klimawandel vorher aus dem wald
entnommen wurde und das waren also das
sind überkapazitäten mit denen man nicht
so geplant hatte die haben natürlich
auch dazu geführt dass die preise extrem
nach unten gegangen sind und die
waldbesitzer dieses holz kam noch
losgeworden sind also so ist dass der
markt sie haben gesagt das ist halt auch
eine der erklärungen es sind viele
punkte die es gibt und wir haben einfach
mal jemanden gefragt ja und kimmig
nämlich den präsidenten der deutschen
säge- und holzindustrie der auch mit
einer erklärung ankommt in deutschland
wird schlichtweg mehr gebaut
mehr gebaut im ein und
zweifamilienhausbau mehr gebaut
natürlich auch in mehrgeschossigen
gebäuden und wir haben durch corona
durch die sondereffekte eine prioritäten
verschieben
die natürlich dazu geführt hat dass
sowohl für den gartenbedarf für ein haus
und garten bedarf aber natürlich auch
speziell was die baugenehmigungen anging
deutlich mehr holz nachgefragt wurde
und wir müssen aufpassen dass wir nicht
in eine situation kommen mit dem
sogenannten toilettenpapier effekt oder
auch mit mit irgendwelchen hamsterkäufen
die dazu führen dass gegebenenfalls die
die preisdiskussion künstlich noch
zusätzlich befeuert wird
tja die toiletten der toilettenpapier
effekte winkler ist das wirklich so das
was ich als die dachlatte auf einmal so
wertvoll wird wie gold und man anfängt
zu halten
das ist auf jeden fall so und es gab
auch ein relativ prominenten schon
gezeigten fall in hannover wo es einen
großen messe baubetrieb gibt wirklich
sehr sehr sehr viel eingekauft hat
einfach um die lager falls ja auto
gekauft habe jetzt hören wir sie wieder
ein bisschen bin ich herr winkler die
letzten 20 sekunden da man sich nicht
gehören zusagen sind nochmal horten sie
jetzt holzwickede hier in corona zeiten
jetzt ab dass alle nicht gehört das ist
ja gut
tatsächlich habe ich mich dabei auch
schon erwischt
ich bin auch schon im baumarkt gefahren
habe outdoor multiplex platten gesehen
und ich habe zwölf stück gekauft
ich habe sie gehofft mal eine packt ich
brauchte gar keine
ich hab sie ins auto gepackt ich habe
mich furchtbar gefühlt aber ich habe
mich halt so schlecht gefühlt dass ich
mich auch nicht getraut habe wieder rein
zu gehen zu sagen hey leute das war
jetzt misst ich habe sie jetzt hinter
mir im lager stehen und ich brauche sie
nicht und dieses dann macht es halt nur
noch schlimmer aber ich habe jetzt
theoretisch irgendwem wahrscheinlich
material weggekauft
und das ist überhaupt nicht richtig also
ich habe mich selten in meiner laufbahn
so schlecht gefühlt weil ich es gekauft
habe also da sind wir den
psychologischen effekt erklären sie mir
einfach mal weil ich jetzt nicht so oft
in den baumarkt rente gebe ich ganz
offen zu die reagieren denn die
baumärkte ich meinen die erinnern uns so
corona zeit dahin dann irgendwann dann
doch mal bei dem klopapier regal bitte
nur eine rolle oder wir zählen auch mal
an der kasse ist das jetzt so dass der
baumarkt hingeht und sagt nur zwei
dachlatten pro person im moment ja nicht
also man muss ja sagen der große vorteil
der gewerbekunden war
wir konnten ja eine ganze zeit mehr oder
weniger alleine in den baumarkt gehen dh
am anfang war es so man war mehr oder
weniger der einzige kunde und konnte
natürlich auch relativ frei einkaufen
jetzt wo sich die situation zuspitzt ist
es schon so dass viele baumärkte nicht
mehr große mengen rausgehen weil es
jetzt nicht zwölf platten sondern ich
sage mal 40 würden die einem
gewerbetreibenden wahrscheinlich gar
nicht mehr mit geben weil sie wissen wie
wir kriegen das gar nicht mehr nach so
zum beispiel bei dachlatten wie ich
aktuell brauche und ich bekomme sie
einfach nicht das einfachste was es auf
dieser welt gibt eine dachlatte ist für
mich im moment nicht zu bekommen und das
ist total verrückt aber ich stelle mir
jetzt mal vor frau professor hartmann
der baumarkt besitzer kennt jetzt herrn
winkler und weiß dass der schlawiner
dinge die er gar nicht braucht auf
vorrat kauft und da geht der baumarkt
jetzt hin und sagt dass man auf wir
machen jetzt eine grenze ab sofort nur
noch ich sag mal zehn dachlatten pro
person oder irgendwas in der richtung so
aber sie wissen vielleicht worauf ich
hinaus will jetzt kommt aber jemand an
der in der reihenhaussiedlung bauten
bauunternehmer der kann ja nicht zehn
dachlatten kaufen sondern muss ja
natürlich weiterhin weil er große
bauprojekte hat und wir alle sind ja
froh wenn die bauwirtschaft ja sozusagen
auch ein motor ist und wenn der jetzt
auf einmal sagt ja ich krieg gar nicht
mehr das was ich brauche um diese rein
aus siedlungen zu bauen
dann hat das doch auch endlich auch
fatale folgen für die gesamtwirtschaft
oder ja natürlich also deswegen laufen
wir in diese lieferengpässe rein also
dieses phänomen mit dem mit dem
toilettenpapier und der bitte man bitte
nur eine packung pro person oder jetzt
hier die daten
das wird natürlich in dem baumarkt zu
einer lösung des problems aber nicht in
der gesamten lieferkette
denn der baumarkt selber ist ja auch
froh wenn er holz geliefert bekommt und
sagt da nicht okay ich nehme nur etwas
weniger weil mein wettbewerber der
braucht ja auch noch was
das passiert ja nicht im gegenteil
dieses diesen wunsch zu horten und jetzt
mehr zu bestellen um dann wieder einen
sicherheits bestand aufzubauen den haben
alle und das verursacht genau diese
probleme in der lieferkette kennen das
in der wertschöpfungskette den
sogenannten peitschen effekt also den
ball wie perfekt man quasi alle
versuchen es wird als synchron geordert
also nicht so wie üblicherweise sondern
man bündelt jetzt ordert ganz viel in
der hoffnung dass wenigstens ein
bisschen was ankommt das machen alle
und das verzerrt sich in der
kommunikation bei den lieferketten dort
also beim lieferanten hört man nur
unglaublich viel nachfrage unglaublich
viel bedarf und man weiß gar nicht wo
man zuerst beliefern soll
und dann wird aber gleichzeitig die
produktion so hoch gefahren dass es dann
in der nächsten stufe wieder zu hohen
lagerbeständen kommt und dann unter
umständen zu dem problem dass die
produkte wieder verfallen bevor sie
verkauft werden können also das ist hat
sich ein ganz verteilers verhalten also
wir lösen damit überhaupt keine probleme
im gegenteil machen sie nur noch
schlimmer
also jemand der im grunde löwen genau
das auch heute gesagt hat was sie
andeuten das ist der präsident des
zentralverbands des deutschen handwerks
herr wollseifer hat nämlich gerade heute
frisch über die probleme gesprochen und
hat eine neue studie bekanntgegeben wo
sie einfach mal bei betrieben umfrage
gestartet haben und 84 prozent davon
sagen dass die aufträge stornieren und
verschieben müssen weil es material ja
eben nicht gibt weil das material an
material mangelt 61 prozent der
lieferengpässe der betroffenen firmen
melden sogar dass durch die preissprünge
unwirtschaftlich werde bestehende
aufträge überhaupt zu erfüllen und am
häufigsten fehlen laut umfragen in den
betrieben aktuell metalle daneben gibt
es engpässe bei holz haben wir schon
besprochen aber auch bei kunststoffen
und elektronikkomponenten also im grunde
genommen das ganze weit gestreut und er
sagt es ist eine noch nie da gewesene
materialknappheit die zu der paradoxen
situation führt dass man volle
auftragsbücher hat da freut man sich
nach corona darüber aber die
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter in
kurzarbeit schicken muss weil es gar
keine arbeit gibt weil man das material
nicht hat also das zeigt schon wie
verrückt das ganze ist und wie
weitreichend die folgen sind ja das ist
dass es genau das problem
wir waren natürlich noch nie in einer
situation in der wir weltweit in
verschiedenen ländern zu
unterschiedlichen zeitpunkten solch
massive einschränkungen des
wirtschaftlichen lebens eingefordert
haben also es war einfach noch nie da
und ich glaube wir
lernen hier gerade extrem viel was
passiert wenn man solche lieferketten
unterbricht und diese effekte die
schaukeln sich eben auch hoch und das
ist nicht so dass das ganz schnell
behoben ist also diese probleme die
werden uns noch einige wochen und monate
begleiten in den lieferketten dagegen
schafft keine guten aussichten für sie
und die anderen do it yourself youtube
nicht wirklich aber auf der anderen
seite finde ich ist das eigentlich wenn
man da was gutes drittel sehen will auch
ganz gut wenn man dann doch mal erkennt
wie global komplex die welt eigentlich
ist ja mit sehr viel über werkzeug noch
nicht gesprochen sondern über holz
metall aber auch im werkzeug bereichen
ist es ja teilweise so dass wir merken
manche sachen können wir da auch nicht
mehr kaufen und das sind glaube ich
immer wieder denkanstöße wo einem selbst
wenn man sage ich mal nur in seiner
garage basteln so ein bisschen klar wird
ja wie komplex unsere welt geworden ist
es ist nicht mehr so dass ich ihn weit
gehen wie ein stück holzkohle und daraus
bauer das war vielleicht mal so aber es
hat sich alles verändert und ich denke
das ist so ein bisschen vielleicht was
positives was man darin sehen könnte das
haben wir in corona zeiten ja sozusagen
leider schon gesehen wenn masken auf
einmal nicht da sind selbstverständliche
arznei oder kittel für mediziner et
cetera und wie auch festgestellt haben
wo wir verlassen uns auf diese globale
welt das alles kommt dass es dieses
timing gibt und wenn irgendetwas schief
läuft dann haben wir das große problem
ja und im moment sind ganz viele dinge
ja gleichzeitig schief gelaufen also wir
hatten einerseits enorme ausschläge bei
der nachfrage also die abnehmerseite hat
sich stark verändert wir hatten enorme
ausschläge auf der herstellerseite durch
die lok tanz und die schließungen der
wirtschaft und gleichzeitig das wurde ja
auch mehrfach berichtet hatten wir
globale lieferprobleme und durch eine
blockade des suezkanals und andere ecken
und dass diese dinge in so massiver form
zusammen kommen das hat unsere
lieferketten ganz schön durchgeschüttelt
wenig neu wie gehen sie denn jetzt mit
ihren auftraggebern um und auch mit
ihrer youtube community sagen sie dir in
stücke oder was auch immer die hängen
doch im suezkanal fest obwohl das schiff
da jetzt los gekommen ist oder wie gehen
sie denn um wie erklären sie das den
iren
followern und was geben sie den für
tipps also im prinzip ist der vorteil
dass wir bei youtube und auch bei den
kunden ja sehr viel massivholz machen
und massivholz gibt es ja noch das ist
schon mal gut das heißt das was ich
immer wieder versuche zu predigen nutzt
mehr massivholz das ist im moment noch
möglich bei kundenaufträgen ist das
nicht ganz so einfach also gerade bei
bestandskunden wo man vielleicht schon
mehrere bürger gebaut hat kann man jetzt
nicht einfach mal sagen hey lass uns
doch mal ein ganz anderes material leben
was überhaupt nicht mehr in deine
wohnung passt ja wie geht man damit um
versuchen es zu kommunizieren und ein
bisschen darauf hoffen dass man
vielleicht auch verständnis trifft
dadurch dass so viele sachen
gleichzeitig schiefgehen wächst das
verständnis zum glück ein paar monaten
war das noch ein bisschen anders und
ehrlich zu sein da war das teilweise
nicht ganz so angenehmen mit den kunden
zu telefonieren
aber im prinzip kann man nicht viel
machen man muss sich an die situation
anpassen und gerade für die youtube
zuschauer kann man vielleicht eine
challenge draus machen und mit möglichst
wenig was möglichst tolles machen auch
wenn das manchmal irgendwie auch sehr
schwierig ist dann ist das doch
sozusagen einen kommentar und eine
lösung sozusagen optimistisch nach vorne
zu blicken und das beste draus zu machen
finde ich eine charmante idee geduld zu
zeigen und dana challenge auch noch
daraus zu machen herr winkler vielen
vielen dank dann drücken wir ihnen
weiterhin alles gute das sie ideenreich
sind und ihre follower community immer
sozusagen bei laune halten ganz
herzlichen dank für die tipps und
informationen bis nach hannover
danke schön ja jetzt haben wir viel über
holz gesprochen
er ist ja nun auch tischlermeister aber
nicht nur dort wird alles knapp wir
haben hier von ihnen auch viele viele
zuschriften schon bekommen wir in der
automobilbranche haben massig probleme
an stahl kunststoffe oder einige
chemikalien zu kommen schreibt deg bei
youtube leider kann ich das gar nicht
nachvollziehen wieso ist das das wäre
eine frage an sie frau hartmann woran
liegt das in der automobilbranche
also da liegt es in großen teilen daran
dass die produktionsstätten so stark
zurückgefahren wurden und jetzt die
rohmaterialien nicht da sind
bei plastik das ist ja ein material das
ja sozusagen eines ein seiten produkt
ist der ölförderung und wir hatten
aufgrund dieser flugeinschränkungen der
einschränkungen im transportwesen hier
massive einbrüche in der ölförderung und
deswegen ist auch das material für
plastik knapp geworden
und auch hier haben wir jetzt natürlich
eine ganz stark steigende nachfrage in
asien in der automobil branche auch in
den usa und hier waren tatsächlich die
hersteller in amerika und in asien auch
sehr viel schneller weil sich dort die
wirtschaft früher erholt hat und haben
schon ihre auftragsbücher wieder gefüllt
und die werden nun im moment etwas
vorrangig bedient also das trägt noch
mit dazu bei dass es diese engpässe auch
in anderen industrien gibt das erinnert
unweigerlich ein bisschen an die
bestellung von impfstoff dass man dann
sagen wo es haben wir nicht wir müssen
uns in geduld üben andere haben früher
und schneller bestellt aber wir wollen
einfach noch mal das beispiel hier was
wir gerade hatten aufgreifen dass es
eben nicht nur um holz geht sondern eben
um viele sachen wir sehen einen kurzen
beitrag dass noch viele dinge knapp
werden rar werden und damit kostbar und
teuer werden wenn die roboters durch
sein fahrradgeschäft in mönchengladbach
geht dann mit sorgenfalten die lücken im
verkauf nehmen zu immer größere
lieferprobleme bei den herstellern der
rat boom freute ihn natürlich aber
mittlerweile gibt sogar bei luftpumpen
engpässe ich sehe mit schrecken in den
herbst wenn wirklich die regale leer
sind und keine ware mehr verfügbar ist
denn die neue ware ist ja auch noch
nicht in zulauf die wird es im späten
herbst kommen oder ins frühjahr kommen
und was bis dahin ist wir haben alle in
der branche etwas angst
anderes beispiel schrauben klein und
doch unverzichtbar
auch hier lange lieferzeiten im letzten
jahr drei bis sechs monate aktuell
warten die händler bis zu einem jahr auf
ware aus fernost löcher in den hoch
lagern und teure frachtraten vor einem
jahr 800 dollar für einen container
derzeit geht's richtung 7.000 wir stehen
vor einem beispiellosen chaos weil wir
einfach die schrauben nicht mehr ran
kriegen die wir für unsere kunden
brauchen und die kunden brauchen sie um
wiederum ihre produkte fertigzustellen
fahrräder solaranlagen spülmaschinen die
wir die sie und ich dann am ende kaufen
möchten und aber nicht kriegen wenn
keine schrauben da sind weltweite hunger
auf material und rohstoffe weil weltweit
nach corona die volkswirtschaften wieder
anspringen auch die deutsche
doch das problem im letzten jahr hielt
sich eine verunsicherte deutsche
wirtschaft mit bestellungen zurück
andere länder waren schneller wieder am
markt
die deutsche wirtschaft hat sich
zurückhalten andere waren schneller am
markt also wie gesagt das klingt schon
erinnert so ein bisschen an die
bestellung von impfstoffen durch die eu
und man muss geduld haben aber verraten
sie einfach mal welche länder haben sich
denn besser angestellt welche länder
haben den schneller reagiert jetzt nur
die usa und china oder auch andere
europäische länder waren die clever
reisen
na ja also es ist ja so ein bisschen
frage der haltung des managements nur
was denke ich wird in der zukunft
passieren und man kann auch nicht
pauschal sagen dass alle deutschen
unternehmen das jetzt irgendwie
verursacht haben oder verschlafen haben
es gab auch in deutschland einige
unternehmen die für sich gedacht haben
wir gehen davon aus dass die pandemie
sich erholt also dass sie vorbei ist und
dass sich dann die wirtschaft auch
schnell erholt es ist nicht nur ein
problem deutschlands und genau so finden
sich natürlich auch beispiele in england
in irland in frankreich und so weiter
also dass man kann es nicht ganz
pauschal global sagen es ist ein
bisschen die tatsache dass ganz europa
in summe stammt von der pandemie
betroffen war auch restriktiver mit der
wirtschaft umgegangen ist
wir wissen auch dass in den usa die lok
downs die ganze zeit nicht so stark
waren wir bei uns natürlich auf kosten
von erkrankungen gegangen
man hat dort die wirtschaft generell
etwas mehr priorisiert als bei uns in
deutschland und in europa wir haben ja
auch nach ihren erfahrungen am anfang
gefragt und raphael lanz schreibt über
facebook das macht eben klar deutlich
sagt er wie abhängig wir von importen
geworden sind china bestimmt die preise
gerade im bereich stahl
da werden die preise enorm explodieren
schreibt er und sie nicht im griff
ja also das wird tatsächlich passieren
also wir haben natürlich durch die
globalisierung sehr lange profitiert nur
globale arbeitsteilung bedeutet ich kann
massiv davon profitieren dass in anderen
ländern
die kosten deutlich günstiger sind dass
liegt meistens an den personalkosten
aber eben nicht nur das hat auch andere
gründe
und hier haben wir im laufe der zeit
sehr sehr viel ausgelagert manchen
unternehmen das glaube ich nicht mehr
bewusst wie viel also wir haben heute in
den meisten industrien eine
durchschnittliche wertschöpfungstiefe
von nur noch 20 bis maximal 50 prozent
das heißt dass ungefähr 50 prozent bis
teilweise 80 prozent und in manchen
unternehmen sogar 100 prozent der
produktiven wertschöpfung ausgelagert
ist in die wertschöpfungskette und die
sind sehr global weit verzweigt die
produkte sind gleichzeitig sehr viel
komplexer geworden das heißt es geht
nicht nur um einen lieferanten sondern
um hunderte tausende in verschiedenen
stufen in dieser wertschöpfungskette und
dieses geflecht
dieses internationale geflecht an
wirtschaftsbeziehungen hat uns
einerseits viel wohlstand beschert aber
führt jetzt natürlich wenn wir den
finger drauf halten an ganz vielen
punkten zu problemen mit denen wir
vorher gar nicht gerechnet haben weil
uns diese vernetzung gar nicht mehr
bewusst ist
also ich greife das auf was raphael lanz
sagt und denke nur daran
selbstverständlich wenn der stahl
günstig aus china kommt klar dann werden
viele produkte günstiger wenn das letzte
stahlwerk in deutschland aber
geschlossen ist das kennt man eben dann
können eben auch die chinesen die preise
bestimmen und erstellen die nicht nach
unten gehen
rene albrecht schreibt über youtube
seine erfahrung privatpersonen wird die
finanzierung des eigenheims mittlerweile
zurückgenommen weil die bank die
stiegen den kosten nicht mehr
finanzieren möchte also hier haben wir
kommen wir noch mal zurück auf den
häuslebauer der tiefer in die tasche
greifen muss bzw der nicht mehr das geld
von der bank bekommt da gibt sich ja
irgendwie die frage wie gehen wir denn
jetzt als verbraucher ganz pragmatisch
damit um der liebe herr winkler sagt wir
müssen ein bisschen geduld haben müssen
irgendwie das beste draus machen aber
ich kann ja jetzt auch nicht hingehen
wir haben es im beitrag geben sagt
gesehen von peter wimmer schrauben also
wenn die auf einmal nicht mehr da sind
dann kann auch die waschmaschine nicht
hergestellt werden also so sind die
zusammenhänge
aber ich kann ja jetzt nicht eine
million schrauben kaufen und die mal auf
vorrat bei mir im garten und
gartenhäuschen bunkern
was kann ich denn als ganz normaler
verbraucher eigentlich tun also als
konsument kann man tatsächlich gar nicht
so furchtbar viel machen also wir sind
ja alle als konsumenten in japan ja
unglaublich kreativ geworden mit
substituten usw
aber gerade beim hausbau geht das nicht
weil die materialien die sie kaufen die
ganze planung es muss alles ineinander
passen das heißt sie können jetzt nicht
einfach sagen okay wenn ich ja kein holz
fensterrahmen bekomme dann nehme ich
halt ein kunststofffenster fensterrahmen
zum einen hat er das gleiche problem
dieser fensterrahmen und zum anderen ist
das unter umständen von der
beschaffenheit nicht passend da bin ich
kein experte nase kann ich nicht so viel
dazu sagen aber was wichtig sein wird
was wir alle aus dieser pandemie lernen
müssen ist tatsächlich dass wir mit
unseren lieferketten ganz anders umgehen
müssen dinge also schrauben nennt man
bei uns klassischerweise c teile sie
heißt unwichtig warum sie brauchen zwar
relativ viele schrauben für die
erstellung eines geschirrspülers einer
geschirrspülmaschine oder einer
waschmaschine aber der wert einer
schraube am endprodukt ist so marginal
dass es nicht beachtet wird im einkauf
also c teile heißt meistens ist ein
unkritisches teil da wird keine
personelle ressourcen dafür abgestellt
oft hat man tatsächlich nur einen
lieferanten weil das ist wie sony
commodity immer verfügbar immer da und
das bedeutet unternehmen haben keine
alternativpläne wenn es mal zu einem
engpass kommt einen alternativplan das
haben sie für die ganz teuren wichtigen
bauteile in einem produkt im kühlschrank
der verdichter also diese kleine
maschine die den kühlschrank viel macht
und und da haben sie ganz oft stark den
fokus drauf da gibt es ganz eng
beziehungen zum lieferanten da gibt es
in der regel frühzeitig bestrebungen
mindestens zwei zu haben dass man im
notfall mais wünschen kann
und jetzt stellen gefestigten c teile
sind doch nicht so unwichtig ich müsste
auf die auf die auch achten und dieses
bewusstsein dass in unternehmen gar
nicht mehr da und das lehrt uns gerade
diese pandemie dass wir tatsächlich
nichts als selbstverständlich nehmen
können sondern dass wir eigentlich alles
was wir produzieren also was wir
einkaufen und in die produktion
transferieren sehr genau unter die lupe
nehmen müssen dass wir viel wissen
müssen darüber wo kommt so ein material
her
wer hat das eigentlich produziert gäbe
ist dennoch eine alternative für den
fall dass da irgendwas passiert und wenn
es eine alternative gebe bekäme ich denn
überhaupt den vertrag mit diesem
lieferanten
das wird heute viel zu wenig gemacht und
ich denke dass sich das massiv verändern
wird als lehre aus dieser partie - jetzt
könnte man ja auch vom umweltpolitischen
aspekt sagen vom nachhaltigkeit effekt
naja dass das was wir bisher gemacht
haben das wird in china produziert das
schräubchen wird ich sag jetzt mal
einfach in brasilien produziert es wird
zusammengefügt et cetera wir nutzen also
diese ganze das ganze globale netzwerk
aber herr winkler hat so schön gesagt
das ist ja verrückt dass die dinge um
den halben globus geschippert werden
nachhaltig umweltfreundlich ist das
nicht kann man sagen dass das vielleicht
auch zu einem umdenken führt oder würden
sie sagen wir können uns nicht aus dem
globalen dorf verabschieden die chips
die in japan hergestellt werden die kann
man nicht mal eben in baden württemberg
herrscht also das wird unterschiedlich
sein je nachdem auf welches produkt wir
schauen und was wir was wir da gerade
einkaufen und es wird immer einige
produkte geben die man hier nicht
produzieren kann 30 sehr speziell sind
und unglaublich viel wissen brauchen
dieses wissen baut sich nicht über nacht
auf und hier gibt es man hat das
exzellenzcluster also es gibt einfach
cluster an lieferanten die meistens in
einer gegend angesiedelt sind das
bekannteste beispiel ist wahrscheinlich
das silicon valley in kalifornien wo
einfach universitäten aber auch software
unternehmen
viele start ups da ist viel geld da wird
für forschungen rein investiert so und
jetzt haben sie diese spezialprodukten
das wird über jahrzehnte aufgebaut
dieses know-how das kann man nicht so
leicht kopieren und das kann man nicht
so leicht vor ort nachbarn aber bei
anderen elementen und anderen produkten
da wird das schon mehr möglich sein und
hier habe ich jetzt natürlich
verschiedene effekte bisher hat es ja
nichts gekostet diese sachen mehrfach um
den globus zu schicken also unsere
logistik kosten sind erschreckend gering
gerade ein so ein containerschiff
gesehen oder passend 50.000 container
drauf sie können sich so grob vorstellen
wie viel material in einen container
reinpasst da können sie unglaublich viel
waren damit transportieren
für das einzelne produkt also diese
transportkosten pro produkt sind so
gering sind meistens unter weit unter
einem prozent
auch wenn es aus asien kommt das
verändert sich jetzt gerade also das
verändert sich mit der einführung eines
co2 preise hier soll sozusagen die
umweltverschmutzung die beim transport
entsteht bepreist werden und und das
versucht man jetzt natürlich zu
implementieren weil man gelernt hat dass
diese globalen lieferketten sehr
umweltschädlich sind weil die
umweltverschmutzung nichts kostet also
muss ich sie in meiner berechnung und in
meine entscheidungs modelle als
unternehmer auch mit aufnehmen und daher
die idee des co2 preises ding ja nicht
nur wir in deutschland haben sondern der
auch in anderen ländern gerade
schrittweise eingeführt wird in der
hoffnung dass das dazu führen wird dass
es nicht mehr so billig ist materialien
und produkte die man auch hier vor ort
herstellen könnte aus asien und anderen
ländern von weither zu importieren da
schließlich so ein bisschen der kreis
weil ich auch noch im ohr habe was herr
winkler eben gesagt hat vielleicht gibt
es ja irgendwo auch etwas positives dass
er durch die preisexplosion jetzt
einfach mal gezwungen sind ein bisschen
umzudenken
derjenige der tief in die tasche greifen
muss und wir haben sehr nette kommentare
von ihnen gehörte und vielleicht ein
haus baut und den kredit nicht mehr
kriegt dem nützt das natürlich nichts da
drücken wir einfach die daumen dass es
andere lösungen noch gibt vielen vielen
dank dass sie da waren dass sie uns so
kompetent die dinge erklärt haben das
globale netzwerk und die folgen
und ich danke auch für an für sie ansage
dankeschön für ihr interesse und wünsche
ihnen noch einen schönen abend
tschüss und wann sie es gut